da zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live eurem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und die sache mit deutschland und
afghanistan die war ja schon lange
kompliziert aber sie wird gerade immer
komplizierter denn die islamischen
milizen der taliban die sind gerade auf
dem vormarsch richtung
der hauptstadt kabul erobern eine
provinz nach der anderen und tausende
menschen sind mittlerweile auf der
flucht vor ihnen insbesondere die
menschen die der bundeswehr geholfen
haben während das ja fast 20-jährigen
einsatzes im land gerade kam die meldung
dass die drittgrößte stadt des landes
herab eingenommen wurde es ist bislang
noch nicht offiziell bestätigt aber die
nachrichtenagenturen bestätigen das und
dass sie eben jetzt die taliban der
hauptstadt kabul immer näher kommen
würden das ganze wurde möglich eben weil
die internationalen truppen nicht mehr
im land sind zumindest zum größten teil
nicht mehr die letzten truppen der usa
werden in den nächsten wochen abgezogen
die bundeswehr ist schon seit ende juni
nicht mehr im land 20 jahre lang war sie
dort im dauereinsatz hat den menschen
dort geholfen hat vor allem die
streitkräfte dort ausgebildet aber diese
ehemaligen hilfskräfte leben jetzt in
angst vor den taliban die
bundesregierung beteuert sie wolle den
menschen dort helfen und auch ihren orts
kräften helfen aber da gibt es auch ein
aber weil damit sind längst nicht alle
gemeint und faktisch ist es für die
menschen die noch gerade im land sind
sehr schwierig und es wird immer
schwieriger ausland rauszukommen darüber
wollen wir heute reden vor allem über
die frage ob deutschland afghanistan im
stich gelassen hat einmal mit meiner
kollegin katrin eigendorf die immer
wieder für uns nach afghanistan gefahren
ist und von dort auch viele
dokumentationen und reportagen
mitgebracht hat und markus kroth jahren
der ist hauptmann der bundeswehr und
afghanistan veteran und hat eine
patenschaft partnerschafts netzwerk
afghanische ortskräfte patenschafts
netzwerk afghanische ortskräfte
gegründet so heißt es und mit dem hilft
er menschen vor ort insbesondere den
ortskräfte neben die jetzt dort gerade
um ihr leben bangen danach wird's
politisch wir sprechen mit dem sprecher
für außenpolitik der grünen
bundestagsfraktion omid nouripour und
dem obmann im innenausschuss der cdu
bundestagsfraktion alexander throm über
die frage wie es mit deutschland und
afghanistan jetzt eigentlich weitergehen
kann wie es mit den hilfskräften die
noch im land dort sind aussieht und auch
mit der frage über die frage was mit den
afghanen hier in deutschland passieren
soll die eigentlich rein juristisch kein
bleiberecht mehr haben aber die frage
ist jetzt wo sollen die eigentliche die
immer eure fragen und kommentare
herzlich gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder an diese adresse
hier
zdf.de ich gucke was ich davon mit drei
nehmen kann und wie immer bei dem thema
bitte bleibt sachlich wir fangen jetzt
aber erst mal an mit meiner kollegin
katrin eigendorf und markus krotki an
hauptmann der bundeswehr und afghanistan
veteran einen schönen guten abend
kathrin ich fange mal bei dir an hättest
du gedacht dass die taliban so schnell
das land wieder versuchen würden unter
ihre kontrolle zu bringen und
tatsächlich auch so schnelle erfolge
verzeichnen können
also dass die taliban versuchen würden
das land so schnell unter ihre kontrolle
zu bringen das hat sich ja schon sehr
früh abgezeichnet im prinzip in dem
zeitpunkt wo die usa einseitig ein
friedensabkommen mit den taliban
vereinbart haben im februar 2020 haben
die islamisten aufwind gespürt und waren
ja im prinzip gestärkt weil man die
afghanische regierung aus diesen
gesprächen völlig ausgeschlossen hat
dass das so schnell geschehen will dass
sie das land praktisch innerhalb
weniger wochen überrannt haben das
überrascht nicht nur mich sondern ich
glaube auch viele militärexperten das
hatte keiner vorausgesehen dass das so
schnell gehen kann wir sehen gerade auch
bei dir im bild ein netzwerk qualität
ist nicht so richtig gut der ton kommt
gut an aber dann bildstock manchmal ein
bisschen wir gucken habt das dort
geregelt kriegen wir gucken muss mal die
karte an von afghanistan wie das gerade
aussieht das heißt wo jetzt die taliban
tatsächlich schon
kontrolle ausüben das ist vor allem im
norden des landes der fall und da sehen
wir die roten flecken das sind die
taliban
gelb ist umkämpft das heißt im land wird
heftig jetzt schon miteinander gerungen
grün oder türkis farben ist sind die
regierung geht und die werden immer
kleiner wie gesagt gerade kam auch die
meldungen dass die drittgrößte stadt
herat mittlerweile in taliban händen
sein soll herr gross jahren aus ihrer
sicht als soldat sie waren ja da sie
stehen mit den menschen auch direkt vor
ort in kontakt wie ist die lage wie
nehmen sie das wahr wie geht es den
leuten dort die sie ja in schutz haben
da kann man ja einfach sich angucken das
in den ländern in der letzten woche ist
einen komplexen angebracht den
verteidigungsminister gab in kabul und
der sprecher der regierung in am
freitagsgebet erschossen wurde alles in
kabul also man sieht wie die auch kabul
immer unsicherer wird kundus ist
gefallen die ortskräfte die sich dort
noch gefunden haben sind mit masse
gestern und vorgestern in kabul
angekommen wir versuchen den unterkunft
zu geben aber natürlich ist das land
beginnt die auch unsere ortskräfte zu
fliehen und nach wie es dann halt so
flüchtlingen geht die sind im stress und
versuchen in sicherheit zu kommen sie
haben da so genannte safe hauses
gegründet oder oder verfügung gestellt
bekommen auch gemietet safe house ist
das klingt jetzt so sicher aber wie
sicher ist das denn tatsächlich wenn
wenn sie auch wissen das ist im grunde
die hauptstadt die auch hart umkämpft
sein wird
naja also einen koordinierten angriff
werden die wohl nicht überleben aber es
sind immerhin 200 meter hohe mauern eine
schleuse vorne zwei wochen mit einer
kalaschnikow jeweils und zwei bunker in
den häusern das ist mehr sicherheit als
sie in jedem hotel hätte oder bei
verwandten und es gibt halt auch nicht
für jeden verwandte in kabul nicht jeder
kann sich da einfach mal so ein zwei
monate einquartieren und wir haben jetzt
tag
32 seitdem wir das erste haus bezogen
haben und wir hatten schon gehofft dass
wir den einen oder anderen vielleicht
meinen so ein flugzeug steigen sehen
würden und statt dessen hat sich halt
leider noch nichts getan und wir haben
noch nicht mal wieder angefangen diese
personengruppe haben sie denn hoffnung
dass er die menschen dann schnell noch
raus bekommen
ganz ehrlich sehe ich das nicht die
dass das büro in kabul er hat bisher
keine anstalten gemacht die arbeit so
aufzunehmen dass ich daran noch glauben
könnte insofern ist die lage der
ortskräfte natürlich vor ort verzweifelt
katrin desaster in einem dieser safe
hause fast das angeguckt kannst ein
bisschen beschreiben wie es da aussieht
ja also die lage ist natürlich so
wirkliche sicherheit kann man bei in so
einem safe house bei einem überfall oder
beide einer machtübernahme der taliban
nicht bieten das ist natürlich nur eine
vorübergehende lösung für die familien
ja da können jetzt die taliban also man
rechnet damit dass ungefähr 10.000
kämpfer sich schon in kabul befinden wir
können natürlich jetzt nicht da einfach
so einbringen diese sicherheit bieten
dieses safe hauses schon aber eine
dauerhafte lösung kann das ja nicht sein
das sind häuser da sind in einem haus in
dem wir gedreht haben gruppe die bilder
auch gerade gesehen haben 15 familien
drin das sind 80 menschen einige der
familien leben zu zweit zu zwei familien
auf einem zimmer an das sind sehr
beengte zuständen das sind natürlich
auch menschen die sich seit wochen unter
extremem stress befinden also wir haben
dort mit einer familie der familie
ansari gedreht die wir auch schon vor
einigen wochen im juni masar i scharif
getroffen haben in ihrem zuhause wo sie
uns schon gesagt haben dass sie sich
nicht sicher fühlen dass sie große angst
haben kurze zeit später sind sie dann
nach kabul geflogen
glücklicherweise gibt es dieses
sehv-auswahl diese familie hat auch
keine verwandten in kabul wusste gar
nicht wohin mit ihren beiden kindern
aber wie gesagt eine dauerhafte lösung
ist das für die ortskräfte sicherlich
nicht stellen können wenn kabul fällt
dann sind alle die die die regierung
unterstützt haben vor allem auch die die
westlichen armeen unterstützt haben ganz
klar ein ziel für die taliban und das
hat man ja auch gesehen bei den städten
die die taliban bis jetzt angenommen
haben hat es massiv gezielte tötungen
gegeben von journalisten von leuten die
mit
internationalen vertretern zusammen
gearbeitet haben also da muss man
wirklich damit rechnen dass diesen
leuten gefahr für leib und leben droht
und auch ihren kathrin vielen dank die
verbindung ist da nicht so richtig gut
wir versuchen hier nochmal aufzubauen
aber wir haben auch dort vor ort gedreht
mit den ortskräfte nachgeschaut was die
zu sagen haben und hier sind mal so zwei
eindrücke
ich kann hier nicht arbeiten ich kann
nicht in die stadt gehen
ich muss das land verlassen ich möchte
dass die deutschen uns an einen sicheren
ort
brauchen sie rausgehen ansonsten alles
was sie brauchen haben wir hier jemanden
beauftragt er alles von draußen rein
bringt zum beispiel das essen getränke
medizin zb da haben wir jemanden der uns
das alles besorgt also dass auch von
unsere unserer gruppe fremde kann
jährlich rainer sogar frage eigentlich
überhaupt nicht rein
herr gut sie an wann ist ihnen klar
geworden dass sie den menschen dort vor
ort helfen müssen das ansonsten nichts
passiert wenn sie nicht selber tätig
werden es war anfang juli habe ich nach
dem nun mehrere wochen verstrichen waren
und es immer wieder aussagen gab dass
man sich der verantwortung bewusst sei
und ich gesehen habe dass die ortskräfte
dort vor ort weder ansprechpartner noch
büros oder irgendwelche möglichkeiten
hatten einen dieser prozess auch nur zu
beginn fing ich an zu überlegen was man
denn so militärisch dann machen würde
wie würde ich menschen in sicherheit
versuchen zu bringen und dazu brauche
ich erstmal sichere unterkünfte und ich
brauche eine möglichkeit das land zu
verlassen deshalb war für mich kabul
denn die die beste möglichkeit und wenn
man anfängt zu kommunizieren dass man
sichere unterkünfte möchte dann gibt es
vielleicht menschen in der gesellschaft
die sehen das ebenso und durch spenden
konnten wir dann das erste mittlerweile
heute haben wir das dritte safe aus
eröffnet mit für insgesamt 340 seelen
die da drin hoffentlich
alsbald den weg nach deutschland finden
können gabriel war für uns da die ideale
ort weil von da gehen die flieger in die
sicherheit und auch da sind die ist das
einzige büro was eigentlich für visa
prozesse nun aufgemacht werden sollte
sehen tun wir das noch nicht aber das
war der grund warum wir uns für kabul
entschieden was werden sie denn tun wenn
das tatsächlich sich der ring in kabul
zu schließen droht werden sie versuchen
die menschen aus der stadt raus zu holen
oder tatsächlich über vielleicht die
ganze nach pakistan zu bringen oder
haben sie für diesen fall gerade
überhaupt keinen plan also erst mal
haben wir noch großen bedarf wir haben
gerade mal 14 15 prozent der ortskräfte
die denn die bedarf angemeldet haben im
cup und überhaupt safe hauses was ich
dann mit denen in drei vier wochen mache
darüber denke ich nach wir geben jetzt
das ganze geld dafür aus dass die eine
temporäre möglichkeit haben in kabul zu
bleiben in der hoffnung dass das in der
regierung vielleicht zu einem umdenken
führen ich habe heute von 2 1 bis 2
schaffer maschinen gehört wie das die
menschen da alle weg bringen kann weiß
ich noch nicht aber lassen wir uns
überraschen vielleicht sind das ja ganz
große flugzeuge und hoffentlich kommen
die weit der außenminister heiko maas
von der spd hat sich heute auch geäußert
zu dem ganzen themenkomplex
wir zeigen euch mal ein paar schnitte
wir haben bereits visa ausgestellt für
2500 personen von denen etwa 1500 schon
in deutschland sind das sind die die für
die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben über
viele viele jahre wenn man sagt man will
auch die mitarbeiter der ngo s oder
andere organisationen aus afghanistan
raus holen dann sind das mehrere
zehntausend wir sind zur zeit dabei ein
bis zwei charter flüge zu organisieren
die bis ende des monats noch einmal eine
größere anzahl von menschen aus dem land
heraus gebracht hat und wir werden dort
wo noch visa zu erteilen sind diese wie
sie jetzt in deutschland ab 1
da muss man jetzt einmal noch erklären
es gibt ja verschiedene personengruppen
die jetzt quasi dort in gefahr sind und
die mit den verschiedenen truppen
zusammengearbeitet haben einmal
tatsächlich die menschen die mit ihnen
direkt zusammengearbeitet haben die auch
bei der bundeswehr angestellt waren dann
gab es vertragspartner der bundeswehr
die wiederum ortskräfte angestellt haben
und daneben die ngo sind wir es nun mal
auf die menschen gucken die ganz direkt
der bundeswehr vor ort geholfen haben
sei es jetzt als vertragspartner
angestellter oder tatsächlich angestellt
hat der bundeswehr haben sie in
verständnis dafür dass da so
unterschieden wird also erstmal möchte
ich die zeilen korrigieren also die 2500
sind die ausgegebenen visa das mag
stimmen aber
wir reden hier von einer gesamt gruppe
von orts kräften mit familienangehörigen
von 7 bis 8000 menschen deshalb bin ich
bei 1700 die in deutschland sind oder
1500 kleinen bei mir nicht die
sektkorken und wenn ich dann überlege
dass von diesen sieben bis 8000 menschen
überhaupt nur 50 prozent ca
antragsberechtigt sind für einen visa
weil aufgrund politischer vorgaben
andere ortskräfte oder echte ortskräfte
die fürs zum beispiel auswärtige amt wo
wir gerade bei dem beispiel sind 2018
gearbeitet haben der ist nicht
antragsberechtigt oder wenn sie für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet haben von
2015 vielleicht aber sie haben noch nie
eine gefährdung sun zeige gemacht dann
können sie heute keinen antrag stellen
das ist ungefähr so als wenn ihr nachbar
sie bedroht und die polizei nimmt nimmt
das nicht auf weil sie wurden in der
vergangenheit noch nie droht dann können
sie jetzt auch nicht
verstehe ich nicht da sind bürokratische
hürden die schließen ganz viele menschen
aus und darüber müssen wir ja auch
erstmal rede also ich erst mal zusammen
sie sehen einmal das problem dass es
menschen gibt die für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet haben in welchem
arbeitsverhältnis auch immer die bisher
nicht gesagt haben wir sind in gefahr
aber sicher ist natürlich in gefahr
sehen und deswegen aber kein recht haben
raus zu kommen weil es quasi keine akute
gefährdungslage gibt das heißt
bundesvergabeamt um die akute
gefährdungslage können sie nicht
anzeigen sie sind nicht
antragsberechtigt sind ausgeschlossen
egal wie gefährlich das leben jetzt ist
sie sind als ort kraft die zum beispiel
das auswärtige amt 2018 gearbeitet haben
können sie keine entscheidung anzeige
stellt nordtrakt werden einen richtigen
vertrag gehabt dass politisch gesehen
ausgeschlossen woher wissen denn die
taliban eigentlich so genau wer mit wem
wann gearbeitet hatte ich meine
afghanistan ist hat weniger bevölkerung
als deutschland ich glaube 36 millionen
werden gezählt aber es trotzdem ein
großes land ist es tatsächlich so
realistisch dass jeder der mal
irgendwann mit einem der truppen zu tun
hatte ist jetzt um sein leben bangen
muss
also das mag dann im einzelfall jeweils
unterschiedlich sagen die gefährdung
aber deshalb fordern wir ja auch eine
einzelfall entscheidung aber die sind ja
ausgeschlossen wie gesagt wenn sie für
2018 bmz gearbeitet haben dann können
sie ja gar keine gefährdung beantragen
gefährdungs anzeige machen aber nach
hundefell herbert dann brauchst du auch
wieder aufwendig das kostet ja auch
wieder zeit das dauert gerade wenn wir
zwischen afghanistan oder so ja ja ja
das ist richtig ärgerlich aber
vielleicht hätte man vorher ein konzept
haben müssen für ortskräfte und wie man
damit umgeht denn ich kann ja nicht
einfach menschen beschäftigen und
hinterher ist es mir dann nicht
kombinieren die dann ist da ja die
bürokratischen hürden sind so groß also
da habe ich immer gelernt dass die
bürokraten die bürokratie folgt den
politischen entscheidungen wenn die
politik sagen würde wir entscheiden
heute 10.000 fälle dann würde es
bürokratische mittel gegen das
abzuarbeiten und ganz ehrlich gesehen
wenn wir jetzt von einer zeitspanne auch
die deutlich länger war es ist ja nicht
so dass das die in den letzten drei
wochen irgendwie eskaliert ist
ergo es ja nicht sehe bei ihnen großes
unverständnis für die derzeitigen
politischen entscheidungen aber glauben
sie denn abschlussfrage dass das gerade
tatsächlich auch im wahlkampf ein thema
ist wo sich einzelne politiker oder
parteien nach vorne wagen ich meine wir
hatten ja immer wieder große
diskussionen in deutschland gerade was
die frage angeht wie nehmen wir hier bei
uns auf
also ganz ehrlich da muss ich sagen wenn
man über politikverdrossenheit redet
dann sollte man vielleicht auch sich so
ehrlich sein und sie jährlich machen und
eine eine position vertreten die man
auch nach der wahl für richtig hält und
auch vor der wahl ich kann doch nicht
politik machen nach tageslaune sondern
man sollte dafür einstehen was man für
richtig hält und dann wählen einen
vielleicht menschen oder halt auch nicht
das ist der demokratische prozess jetzt
so zu tun als wenn man vor der wahl
irgend etwas nicht macht und dann
hinterher macht man es doch das wird
doch genau dazu dass die leute hinterher
den politikern das vorhalten und sagen
ich brauche ich doch gar nicht zu hören
warum macht man hier nicht etwas wo man
ganz klar festlegen kann jemand der zehn
oder zwölf jahre für uns gearbeitet hat
und aufgrund dessen ermordet werden soll
das ist doch keine große frage aus
moralischer sicht dass ich dem helfe und
das ist auch strategisch sinnvoll ist
das kommt ja noch dazu also in mali da
haben ja auch heutzutage entließ die
sehen ja auch die deutsche mit ihren
ortskräfte umgehen was ist denn wenn da
keiner mehr übersetzt sprechen denn
viele von uns die landessprachen sowie
eingesetzt werden ich habe das letztes
mal nicht so wahrgenommen sagt markus
grothe jahren afghanistan veteran und
helfer der mit seinem netzwerk versucht
menschen in kabul und in afghanistan die
für die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben so
schnell wie möglich aus dem land zu
bringen vielen dank herr kurz währen
dass ihr heute zeit für uns hatten
die ganze lage in afghanistan die
diskussion um die hilfskräfte um
aussetzung von abschiebungen die hat
auch heute natürlich wieder die politik
beschäftigt wir schauen uns das mal in
der zusammenfassung an
in afghanistan fällt provinzhauptstadt
um provinzhauptstadt die taliban haben
nun auch gar nie eingenommen 150
kilometer vor der hauptstadt kabul und
auch für die ehemaligen ortskräfte wird
die lage immer gefährlicher
in sogenannten safe hauses in geheimen
unterkünften hat ein ziviler verein etwa
300 von ihnen in kabul untergebracht
einer der für die bundeswehr tätig war
und heute in deutschland lebt erzählt
dass es für viele gerade unmöglich ist
offiziell die ausreise zu beantragen
wenn sie einen pass beantragen natürlich
das dauert sehr sehr lang und für die
orts möchte da sie die sechs häuser
nicht verlassen dürfen ja sie können
auch nicht so einfach gehen und besser
werden tragen sie müssen das alles
geheim halten dass die menschen nicht
aufmerksam werden das sind karin
hoffmann ehemaliger afghanischer
ortskräfte geben in der deutschen
politik scheint unterdessen eine art
schwarzer peter spiel begonnen zu haben
wer für die schleppende evakuierung
verantwortlich ist die
verteidigungsministerin sieht die schuld
bei der afghanischen regierung
der limitierende faktor liegt zurzeit
darin dass die afghanische regierung
darauf besteht dass die die ausreißen
einen afghanischen reisepass haben der
kanzlerkandidat der union dagegen
kritisiert heute mittag überraschend das
auswärtige amt ich höre über was da
alles bürokratisch hin und her
diskutiert wird
und ob der flug bezahlt wird und nicht
bezahlt wird das auswärtige amt scheint
da
einige bürokratische hemmnisse
aufzubauen diese menschen müssen sehr
schnell eine chance haben nach
deutschland zu kommen
aus dem auswärtigen amt zu diesem
vorwurf bislang keine stellungnahme
schon am morgen allerdings hatte der
außenminister öffentlich hilfe in
aussicht gestellt wir sind zur zeit
dabei ein bis zwei starter flügel zu
organisieren die bis ende des monats
noch einmal eine größere anzahl von
menschen aus dem land heraus gebracht
hat und wir werden dort wo noch lisa zu
verteilen sind diese wie da jetzt in
deutschland sei die sicherheitslage am
hindukusch unterdessen verschlechtert
sich stündlich
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
dem sprecher für außenpolitik der grünen
bundestagsfraktion omid nouripour bei
mir im studio schönen guten abend ruhig
und ich begrüße bei uns auf der leinwand
den open an den innenausschuss der cdu
bundestagsfraktion alexander throm auch
halo
genannt ich fand mal bei ihnen an herr
drohen also laut bundesinnenminister
innenministerium sind rund 30.000
afghaninnen und afghanen in deutschland
ausreisepflichtig darunter auch frauen
und familien war es richtig die
abschiebungen nach afghanistan
einzustellen
na ja wir bekommen natürlich dramatische
berichte aus afghanistan die letzten
tagen und wochen und die das ist eine
große dynamik drin in der entwicklung in
afghanistan im vorigen der taliban und
insofern musste die sicherheitslage
regelmäßig neu bewertet werden
das ist jetzt gerade in den letzten tag
nochmals erfolgt und insofern ist es
jetzt zunächst einmal richtig dieser
akuten situation die abschiebungen
auszusetzen kritiker sagen aber die lage
im land war immer schon schwierig die
war nie 100 prozentig sicher und man
hätte das ganze viel früher aussetzen
müssen warum erst jetzt also muss
tatsächlich erst wieder die taliban
komplett in die vollen gehen um damit
der innenminister sagt okay jetzt jetzt
reicht's
na ja es gibt schon eine
unterschiedliche situation
derzeit vor abzug der bundeswehr und
anderer streitkräfte und auch in der
entwicklung die letzten wochen und
monate es gab und gibt auch nach wie vor
immer weniger aber es gibt nach wie vor
auch sichere regionen und gleichwohl hat
die bundesregierung entschieden dass in
der aktuellen akuten situation wo es
auch nicht ganz übersichtlich ist wie
die situation sich darstellt
abschiebungen nicht stattfinden aber ich
will schon sagen zuvor wurden
nahezu ausschließlich schwere straftäter
gefährder
abgeschoben also menschen die mit
sicherheit kein bleiberecht bei uns in
deutschland haben und das war auch
jedenfalls richtig herr nouripour
schüttelt mit dem kopf sie haben
widerspruch ich habe viele widersprüche
erstens hat die bundesregierung oft
gesagt lange gesagt es gäbe sicher
region sie haben bis heute keine einzige
genannt ich würde gerne vom kollegen
wissen welcher region eigentlich sicher
war vor drei vier monaten als alle zehn
minuten ein anschlag erfolgt ist in
afghanistan vor einem jahr ich habe
jetzt die liste bekommen da diejenigen
die abgeschoben worden sind und woher
sie kommen und da ist kundus konto
sitzen den letzten drei jahren viermal
erobert worden von den taliban ist dass
einer dieser sichere region und zweitens
ist es einfach schlicht nicht richtig
dass ausschließlich verbrecher
abgeschoben worden sein ich habe selber
leute vor ort in kabul getroffen und
gefunden die die einfach keinerlei
verbrechen begangen haben ja es gibt
leute die ausreisepflichtig sind aber
die frage ja 30.000 sie haben sie gesagt
aber das hängt natürlich auch davon ab
ob die sicherheitslage ist vor ort her
gibt und diese frage von das waren alles
straftäter ist eigentlich nur ein alibi
hinter dem man sich verstecken was nicht
einmal stimmt ich kenne wie gesagt
einzelfälle wo er ist nicht der fall war
jetzt sind die abschiebungen ausgesetzt
das heißt es wird irgendwann wieder
abschiebungen geben ab welchem punkt
würden sie sagen kann man wieder nach
afghanistan menschen bringen wenn die
sicherheitslage ist wieder hergibt wir
haben aber jetzt derzeit eine situation
die eine dynamik anmuten lässt die er
komplett in die andere richtung geht die
frage ist ob ihm drei monaten die
regierung in kabul noch da ist oder ob
die taliban das land überrannt haben das
werden wir sehen und dann wird man noch
mal miteinander reden müssen ob auf
absehbare zeit eine eine abschiebung
nach afghanistan überhaupt noch den aber
wie sicher muss das land denn sein da
scheint es ja zwischen ihnen und herrn
toben durchaus unterschiedliche
definitionen von sicher zu geben wir
haben einen riesen unterschied in der
frage wie man die grundlage für
abschiebungen nämlich den asyl
politischen lager bericht des
auswärtigen amtes hersteller wir sind
der meinung dass man vor ort auch mal
leute fragen muss dass man auch nicht
regierungsorganisation fragen muss es
gibt in afghanistan beispielsweise das
vielzitierte afghan analysts network die
wirklich von region zu region jeweils
auch analysen machen
aber deren impulse kommen in diesem
bericht nicht vor es gibt aber jetzt
bisher den usus der bundesregierung dass
man einfach vom schreibtisch aus
schreibt ist ein land sicher oder nicht
und das muss nicht sein wir haben aber
doch durchaus auch diplomaten vor ort
wir haben einschätzungen der
sicherheitsdienste die das ja auch
einschätzen können wie das land aussieht
also da muss es doch auch auf dieser
stimmen muss auch gehört werden auch
diese müssen einfließen zweifelsohne
allerdings möchte ich darauf hinweisen
dass man zwei sicherheitsschleusen
gebraucht hat bis man die in die
botschaft in kabul überhaupt noch rein
gekommen ist ich war im februar 2020 das
letzte mal da dass diese leute sich frei
bewegen und jetzt ernsthaft wissen
können dass in urusgan beispielsweise
die sicherheitslage gut oder schlecht
ist das ist nicht wirklich möglich die
sind viele viele seit jahren nicht mehr
wirklich raus gefahren das klingt alles
nicht so gut und wenn wir uns angucken
wie afghanistan den letzten 40 jahren
ausgesehen hat vielleicht sogar noch
länger dann muss man ja sehen eigentlich
das land ist nie wirklich zur ruhe
gekommen es gab immer
auseinandersetzungen von verschiedenen
kriegsparteien ist es nicht erst mal
zeit einzusehen dass afghanistan nie
wirklich sicher war und auch auf lange
zeit nicht sicher sein wird so dass wir
da eigentlich keine menschen mehr
hinbringen können
also zwar gehört auch dass die grünen
insbesondere noch zu keinem zeitpunkt in
afghanistan eine ausreichende sicherheit
gesehen haben und der menschen
zurückzuführen
und ich habe gesagt dass wir weit
überwiegend straftäter und gefährder und
identitäts teuscher nach afghanistan
zurück gebracht haben und
selbstverständlich war beispielsweise
kabul laut der einschätzung des
auswärtigen amtes eine sichere region
wohin zurückgeführt werden konnte jetzt
haben wir aktuell eine andere situation
die ich sage es noch mal sehr dynamisch
ist und die wir beobachten müssen und
deswegen auch in regelmäßigen abständen
prüfen müssen ob und wenn ja unter
welchen bedingungen rückführungen wieder
möglich werden aber haben sie sind sie
wirklich dann an die festhalten an der
aussage dass menschen die hier in
deutschland kein bleiberecht haben auch
wieder zurück müssen aber haben sie
wirklich die hoffnung dass dieses land
in den nächsten zehn bis 20 jahren unter
kontrolle zu kriegen sein würde ich
meine die dynamik die wir gerade sehen
die haben wir noch vor 20 jahren gesehen
das ist ja das wiederholt sich hat die
ganze zeit also ich habe afghanistan in
meiner lebenszeit noch nie wirklich als
ruhiges und sicheres land wahrgenommen
das muss ich leider bestätigen das ist
meiner lebenszeit ähnlich jedenfalls
soweit ich mich zurückerinnern kann und
ich gestehe zu dass die perspektive
jetzt wird die nächsten monate und die
nächsten zeit nicht positiv ist
gleichwohl gilt es dieses zu beobachten
und immer wieder auch durch das
auswärtige amt die sicherheitslage neu
zu beurteilen jetzt muss man sagen herr
nouripour kein bleiberecht ist kein
bleiberecht das ist juristisch so
geregelt da hat ein richter oder eine
richterin darauf code hat gesagt diese
menschen haben hier eigentlich nichts
das recht zu bleiben
wie soll das juristisch geregelt werden
dass man diese menschen vielleicht dann
doch irgendwann wieder zurück führt wenn
man einfach feststellen dieses land
bleibt immer in dieser unruhe das ist ja
kein phänomen von afghanistan wir haben
dieselbe debatte ich finde auf einer
viel niedrigerem auf den vielen regionen
niveau bei syrien wir haben jetzt eine
spd spitzenkandidatin in berlin die seit
wochen sagt afghanistan syrien dorthin
müsse man abschieben wohin man dort
abschieben soll das hat sie bisher noch
nicht erklärt es gibt die notwendigkeit
dass diejenigen die keinen die
ausreisepflichtig sind ausreisen
gleichzeitig gilt dass diese menschen
vor ort wo sie hinkommen auch sicher
sind sicher sein können sicher leben
können und wir unter streiten uns jetzt
gerade streichen jetzt gerade nicht über
die gesetzeslage wir streiten über die
bewertung was denn eigentlich sicher ist
und welches land sich nicht sicher ist
und ich glaube dass die bilder aus
afghanistan gerade extrem deutlich
machen dass afghanistan für eine
abschiebung zur zeit überhaupt nicht in
frage kommt und ich bin extrem froh dass
endlich endlich der bundesinnenminister
das eingesehen hat und wir jetzt erst
mal dieses thema jetzt beenden können
und jetzt wieder nicht die ganze zeit
wahlkampfrhetorik von uns geben müssen
alle seiten sondern das ist jetzt
erledigt und das ist gut und ich fürchte
das wird auch so bleiben und die furcht
ist nicht weil abschiebungen per se
falsch sind sondern die furcht ist
deswegen war die lage in afghanistan so
dramatisch schlecht jetzt gehen wir mal
in die andere richtung wir haben über
abschiebungen gesprochen von deutschland
nach afghanistan ist hatten wir gerade
schon mit herrn prozeus die diskussion
was ist mit den hilfskräften die dort
noch vor ort sind und die darauf warten
und hoffen dass sie nach deutschland
kommen können was würden sie sagen herr
nouripour lässt deutschlands seine
hilfskräfte seine ortskräfte im stich es
ist gerade der heutige tag belegt dafür
und die verunsicherung der jetzt erfolgt
das über die verschiedenen
widersprüchlichen aussagen das ist ja
zum zu melden der außenminister sagt
erstmal wir holen die her und dann
prüfen wir dann sagt tagsüber der
vorsitzende der cdu armin laschet na ja
das problem sei das auswärtige amt würde
jetzt nicht ausreichend schnell genug
prüfen nachmittag sagte dann die
verteidigungsministerien das problem
sind die afghanen die pässe nicht
ausreichend herausgeben das ist einfach
zutiefst widersprüchlich und schafft
noch mehr verunsicherung wir haben eine
moralische verpflichtung für diejenigen
die jetzt in lebensgefahr sind weil sie
den deutschen geholfen haben und wir
haben einen ruf zu verlieren in der welt
und zwar nicht nur in afghanistan wenn
sich herumspricht du hilfst den
deutschen und am ende bist du alleine
gelassen im stich gelassen dann wird uns
auch draußen in mali oder anderen
einsatzgebieten die man mir helfen und
wenn der außenminister sagt na ja es
geht ja um bundeswehr nicht um ngo ist
dann blendet er beispielsweise herr
großmann hat wundervoll gerade gesagt da
blendete einfach aus dass das leute gibt
die jetzt gefährdet sind weil sie den
diplomaten geholfen haben weil sie den
entwicklungshelferin helfern geholfen
haben und das dient nicht zu helfen
heißt dass sie wirklich ein ziel sind
für taliban weil es auch ein exempel an
denen statuiert werden kann dass wenn
man diese leute eingeht dass die sich
zukünftig auch niemand mehr trauen wird
den international zu helfen ist das
nicht ein gutes argument herum dass man
sagt okay wir tatsächlich die menschen
in afghanistan lassen sie nicht zu uns
rüber holen teilweise weil es schwierig
ist aber auch teilweise weil sie gar
nicht nach den geltenden regeln das
recht haben zu kommen dass es dann in
anderen auslandseinsätzen richtig
schwierig werden kann
also klar ist wir haben eine große
verantwortung gegenüber unseren
ortskräfte unseren ehemaligen ortskräfte
und ihren familien das haben wir aber
von anfang an gesagt nachdem der abzug
der bundeswehr fest stand aber waren
diese ganze karriere panische schreie
hat vereinfacht wir haben die regularien
wenn ich das sagen darf wenn ich das
sagen darf die regularien die grad
vorher auch insbesondere
angesprochen worden sind deutlich
erweitert gerade für angehörige
ortskräfte die bei der bundeswehr und
beim bundesministerium des innern
gearbeitet haben weil wir da unsere
verantwortung gerecht sind und haben
auch jetzt in dieser relativ kurzen zeit
bereits 2400 aufnahme zusagen für
familien und ortskräfte erteilt und 1500
bis 1700 sollen auch schon in
deutschland seien aber klar ist es
wirklich auch deutlich zum ausdruck
bringen für diese arbeitskräfte tragen
wir verantwortung und wir müssen jetzt
nachdem die lage sich sehr schnell in
den letzten tagen verändert hat auch
schauen dass wir sie schnellstmöglich
nach deutschland bringen wir hat die
verteidigungsministerien kramp
karrenbauer heute erklärt dass wir
beispielsweise auch beim sogenannten
visa verfahren eine umkehr der
vorgehensweise vornehmen so dass es
schneller geht wieso verfahren dann erst
in deutschland und insofern glaube ich
dass das alles zeigt dass wir wissen
worauf es ankommt aber haben wir dich
auch eine verantwortung für die
ortskräfte die nicht direkt der
bundeswehr geholfen haben also die nicht
direkt angestellt worden sind sondern
die über vertragspartner angestellt
worden sind die haben ja derzeit nicht
das gleiche recht wie andere
nein da gibt es unterschiede wir haben
dies zunächst mal jetzt für diese
arbeitskräfte
beschlossen die bundeswehr und
bundesministerien des innern
angestellt waren auch andere ortskräfte
beispielsweise vom auswärtigen amt haben
die möglichkeit eine gefährdung sun
zeige zu erstatten allerdings gibt es da
noch die regel dass es nur zwei jahre
zurückreicht aber es das recht herr
werden entsprechend bearbeitet
also zunächst einmal ist es wichtig dass
er glaube ich die die unmittelbar
gefährdet sind und das sind nach
einschätzung des auswärtigen amtes das
will ich betonen die ehemaligen
angehörige bei der bundeswehr und beim
bundesministerium des innern und ich
gehe mal davon aus dass das auswärtige
amt sich auch um seine ortskräfte oder
ehemalige ortskräfte entsprechend
bemühen wird nochmals das sind die
aussagen die mir bisher hierzu vom
auswärtigen amt aber ist es gerecht noch
mal die frage so zu unterscheiden
zwischen menschen die in verschiedenen
arbeitsverhältnissen gearbeitet haben
weil die gefährdungslage ist ja dieselbe
also es ist schon notwendig hin zu sehen
wo es unterschiede gibt und da gibt es
die zusage insbesondere für die us
kräfte vom verteidigungsministerium und
ministerium des inneren weil es da
momentan durch den wegzug der bundeswehr
eine andere situation gibt wird aber
auch bei anderen orts kräften der
bundesregierung gibt es das sogenannte
ortskräfte verfahren wo die gefährdungs
anzeige erfolgen kann erfolgen soll und
wir haben die partner in kabul eine neue
anlaufstelle wo es leichter und
schneller möglich sein soll aber sie
drücken sich darum herum wer zu sagen
was mit den menschen ist die
vertragspartner gearbeitet haben die
werden einfach de facto gerade nicht
berücksichtigt ist das gerecht
nochmal es geht darum dass wir
diejenigen berücksichtigen die bei der
bundeswehr wurde bei der bundesregierung
als ortskräfte gearbeitet haben da gibt
es ein ortskräfte verfahren das es
beschleunigt worden das gilt zunächst
für alle und für diejenigen die
bundeswehr und bundesministerium des
inneren gearbeitet haben ist es nochmals
deutlich erweitert geworden und
entbürokratisiert worden und ich glaube
das wird der situation jetzt momentan
gerecht wir sollten uns darauf
konzentrieren dass die zumindest
diejenigen
die das betrifft dann auch möglichst
schnell nach deutschland holen aber auch
wenn ich drei mal widersprechen noch
einmal es das nicht gerecht weil das
sind leute die den deutschen geholfen
haben und jetzt das wege lebensgefahr
sind zweitens gilt das nicht für alle
die auch für die für für die
bundesregierung gearbeitet haben weil
diejenigen die dem der gesellschaft für
internationale zusammenarbeit zum
beispiel beigestanden haben das ist eine
bundeseigene durchführungs organisation
für entwicklungszusammenarbeit die sind
nicht in diesem kontinent und dass die
sind einfach raus genommen das heißt
auch das stimmt nicht und das dritte ist
weg helfen erstmal den einen und dann
schauen wir mal was mit den anderen ist
blendet einfach den zeitdruck aus hinte
gerade massiver leben es fallen gerade
die die provinzhauptstädte wie die idee
kartenhäuser und wenn es schlecht läuft
ich will das nicht beschwören ist kann
auch wieder stabilisiert werden wir
wissen es nicht dann fallen demnächst
auch die großstädte und demnächst kann
auch in zwei wochen sein und dann gibt
es einfach keine zeit mehr um zu gucken
dass wir demnächst mal jetzt mal schauen
ob wir die bürokratie abbauen und
nachdem wir den einen schauen wir mal ob
er den anderen das problem ist ja nicht
neu der zeitdruck ist ja nicht
überraschend wir diskutieren seit jahren
in den ausschüssen im
verteidigungsausschuss beispielsweise
seien mindestens fünf sechs jahren
dieses thema und jetzt kommt es zum
schwur und die bundesregierung ist
einfach nicht da für diese leute da
kommt es aber dann irgendwann auf die
frage wie viele menschen können wir aus
dem land holen wir haben hat herrn
gerade gehört der von mehreren
zehntausend sprach also irgendwo muss
man dann noch mal sagen okay die ihr
kommt noch mit in diesem pool und hier
ist jetzt mal schluss auch wenn du der
zweite schwager vom dritten onkel bis
der mit diesen menschen mal irgendwann
was zu tun hatte der der bundesweiten
hat hier und es geht um logistik und der
evakuierung wirklich hin zeit einmal wo
würden sie schluss machen wo sagen sie
das ist ehrlich gesagt ist es derzeit so
die amerikaner haben eine bessere
regelung haben ein weit umfassenderen
begriff derjenigen dem die sie helfen
wollen und die haben die charterflieger
auch jetzt schon laufen die ganze zeit
sind auch weit mehr als 2 und die sagen
jetzt schon dass sie wahrscheinlich
nicht mal herauskriegen werden weil die
situation so weit eskaliert dass heißt
es geht jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht darum
dass wir jetzt über zahlen räsonieren
dass wir einfach helfen und diejenigen
die bedroht sind dadurch dass sie uns
geholfen haben die haben diese hilfe
verdient ich gucke jetzt mal endlich in
die kommentare ich habe euch ein
bisschen vernachlässigt liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer bis hier
hin dass das immer bei einer diskussion
bisschen schwierig auch noch hier darauf
zu gucken aber das tue ich jetzt die
zeit nehme ich mir also cent und
schreibt auf facebook die amis haben die
afghanen im stich gelassen das ist kann
man so sehen die usa haben mit ihren
ankündigungen sich aus dem land
zurückgezogen ja quasi dafür gesorgt
dass überhaupt also truppen gesagt haben
okay dann gehen wir auch silke stark ist
der meinung war doch klar dass die
taliban nur darauf gewartet haben und
gentleman meint ihr auf youtube ich bin
extrem kritisch was migrationspolitik
betrifft und gegen diese alles rein
nummer doch diese leute müssen wir
unterstützen und direkt den deutschen
person aushändigen denn die haben uns
unterstützt da würde ich mal die frage
ein traum geben würden sie das auch so
sehen also menschen die uns geholfen wir
haben ein anrecht hier sich
niederzulassen dauerhaft und auch die
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft zu kriegen
also wenn die ortskräfte die gefährdungs
anzeige machen die zustimmung der
bundesregierung vorliegt dass sie so
verfahren durchgeführt worden ist die
sicherheitsüberprüfung durchgeführt
worden ist dann haben sie ein
bleiberecht in deutschland
das ist dann eine sonderregelung im
aufenthaltsgesetz deswegen haben sie
dann auch nach entsprechenden zeitablauf
die möglichkeit natürlich hier deutsche
staatsbürger zu werden und sich
entsprechend zu integrieren aber das
sind zweite dritte vierte schritt wir
müssen glaube ich zunächst einmal eben
schauen wie die gefährdungslage ist
konkret auf die personen bezogen und
dann diese so schnell wie möglich auch
nach deutschland holen das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen ich will ausdrücklich
auch noch mal betonen dass ich mich
heute gefreut habe als ich gehört habe
dass die bundesregierung auch ein
charterflüge denkt um die ausreise zu
ermöglichen
das ist eine frage die auch israel auf
youtube hat hätte man die helfer die
beispielsweise übersetzer gearbeitet
haben nicht gleich mit charterflügen aus
der region heraus kriegen können warum
hat man das bislang nicht getan ich weiß
nicht wer von ihnen darauf antworten ich
kann diese frage nicht beantworten wir
haben sehr jahrelang darüber gesprochen
wir haben seit wochen darauf hingewiesen
es gibt einen sehr sehr gefächerten
brief von einem zahlreichen afghanistan
expertinnen und experten der ist im mai
oder anfang juni der bundesregierung
zugegangen genau mit dieser forderung
was seitdem passiert ist das müssen sie
die bundesregierung fragt haben sie eine
antwort darauf warum
also wir haben sofort von anfang an
gesagt dass wir unserer verantwortung
bewusst sein haben des
angriffs fahrer beschleunigt und
entschlackt und haben und haben auch
bereits 1500 bis 1700 menschen
tatsächlich in deutschland in diesen
wenigen wochen und monaten aber ich
glaube es gehört auch dazu gerade vor
nicht so in ihrer kollegin gesagt worden
dass es schon überraschend ist in
welcher schnelligkeit und mit welcher
dynamik die taliban land gewinne in
afghanistan haben und insofern ist jetzt
noch mal eine andere situation
eingetreten und das sehen sie ja auch an
den maßnahmen die frau kramp karrenbauer
beispielsweise gesagt was das
visaverfahren anbelangt oder auch die
überlegungen anbelangt charterflüge zu
ordern jetzt könnte die
taliban-herrschaft die dort droht herr
maas sprach schon von einem drohenden
kalifat was dort kommen könnte und dann
würde auch das geld ja entzogen das
deutschland dorthin schickt das könnte
ja menschen zum flüchten veranlassen
tatsächlich auch wieder vermehrt
richtung europa wie sollte europa und
die eu damit umgehen darum ja
das ist in der tat eine große sorge die
uns umtreibt dass wir sehen die
flüchtlingsbewegungen unabhängig auch
von den orts kräften in afghanistan auch
in nachbarländer von afghanistan und
deswegen ist unsere forderung und
erwartung auch an die europäische
kommission dass wir zunächst einmal in
den nachbarländern auch entsprechend
unterstützt und dort für hilfsmaßnahmen
für die flüchtlinge aus afghanistan zu
sorgen denn eins ist auch klar
es darf keine entwicklung geben wonach
wieder große zahlen von flüchtlingen
nach europa und insbesondere nach
deutschland kommen wir müssen schauen
dass wir den menschen vor ort
beziehungsweise insbesondere in den
nachbarländern entsprechende
unterstützung geben
wie könnte die aussehen anregung ich
glaube erstens dass es nicht die
richtige zeit ist um über diese frage
länger zu sprechen denn wir wissen es
nicht und alle rufe es werden alle
fliehen bedeuten die taliban werden
gewinnen und die teile waren leben genau
von diesem ruf talokan ein auch ein
ehemaliger standort der bundeswehr ist
gefallen weil fälschlicherweise kundus
stadt ist ja bis heute nicht komplett
gefallen
fälschlicherweise die nachricht
herumgehen kunde sei gefallen daraufhin
sind die sie am ehesten alle gegangen
und die taliban haben die stadt einfach
übernommen dh es ist ganz viel
psychologie und wenn wir jetzt so tun
als wäre afghanistan schon verloren dann
werden die leute auch keine hoffnung
mehr haben dann haben sie drei
möglichkeiten entweder sich warlords
anschließen in den flächendeckenden
bürgerkrieg oder den taliban oder sich
auf den weg machen und deshalb ist die
frage wie man jetzt noch verhindern kann
dass die taliban das land verhindern die
zentrale frage und ich glaube dass das
gespräch gebraucht mit der afghanischen
regierung die sehr viel autorität
verloren hat durch das agieren
amerikaner in den letzten wochen und
monaten dass man einfach mit denen redet
jenseits von militäreinsätzen und die
die geduld unserer öffentlichkeit ist zu
ende das ist ja der grund für den
absolut gewesen aber jenseits dessen was
die sondern ich finde hilfe brauchen mir
fehlt ein kräftiges signal der
solidarität mit der regierung dass wir
noch glauben dass sie da sind dass wir
glauben dass sie noch eine chance haben
denn den den hebel umzulegen und das ist
ehrlich gesagt das allerwichtigste in
diesen tagen dass die afghanische
regierung noch eine chance hat und wie
ihr eine sichtbare chance gegeben dass
sie das bestehen können ich sehe 2
kommentare die würde ich gern mal
vorlesen wenn immer auf meinen rechner
schaltet
einmal von patrick der schreibt
terrorgruppen einfach komplett
zerschlagen und gut dann gibt es auch
frieden und darüber von janney der oder
die schreibt wir brauchen härtere leute
an der front die die taliban in die
hölle servieren
ist das tatsächlich so also was würden
sie sagen herr nouripour war der einsatz
der falsche ist dort nicht mit richtigen
mitteln gekämpft worden oder war er
vielleicht war es auch ein fehler
abzuziehen darum
naja es war auf jeden fall eine sehr
schnelle nicht zu sagen ein übereilter
abzug ausgelöst durch die entscheidung
der amerikaner
bei denen sich dann auch deutschland und
andere länder
entsprechend angeschlossen haben ja
vielleicht sogar an schließen
mussten
ich finde man sieht aber auch auf der
anderen seite was es gebracht hat in
diesen 20 jahren des einsatzes wenn man
jetzt gerade aussieht wie schnell sich
da leider zum negativen verändert man
hat afghanistan schon eine chance
gegeben und das müssen jetzt die
afghanen die afghanische regierung auch
ein stück weit selbst in die hand nehmen
da gebe ich ja nur recht mit
unterstützung dass wir weiter tun müssen
und es ist viel psychologie auch das
wurde gesagt oder auch die frage welche
signale
aussenden an die afghanische regierung
auch an die bevölkerung aber eben auch
in den blick auf macht es sinn sich auf
den weg nach europa zu machen auch da
müssen wir glaube ich deutlich unsere
signale senden dass dies nicht der
richtige weg ist also ein überstürzter
abzug aus der sicht von herrn strom
hätten wieso ist europa überhaupt
verpflichtet afghanistan zu retten wieso
zum teufel ist das bitte unsere
baustelle herum es gibt eine reihe von
gründen die man benennen kann wobei ich
ganz normal zu den fehlern zurückkommen
würde gerne es gibt eine riesen reihe an
andern anderen fehlern die gemacht
worden sind in den letzten 20 jahren und
die haben dazu geführt dass einiges
erreicht worden ist aber nicht
ausreichend was hätte möglich sein
müssen und können damit die situation
des trotzdem stabil ist was sie nicht
ist so wenig hatte leute an der front
das also das militär war aber wahr was
zu wenig militär was nicht sondern das
war zu wenig staatsaufbau zu viel
aufwand setzen zu wenig die
zivilgesellschaft unterstützen und
vieles mehr es ist dringend notwendig
dass man aufzuarbeiten und eine
unabhängige bewertung dieses einsatzes
zu fahren wogegen sich leider die
bundesregierung seit jahren verwahrte
ich habe keine ahnung warum es wäre
jetzt dringend überfällig
es ist notwendig auch im übrigen zu
sehen und da gebe ich dem kollegen
absolut recht dass die tage waren ganz
viel versprochen haben und sich an
nichts bisher gehalten haben sie haben
versprochen frauenrechte aufrecht zu
erhalten wo sie hinkommen ist natürlich
das gegenteil der fall sie haben
versprochen dass die
friedensverhandlungen führen werden nach
dem abzug stattdessen machen sie den
vormarsch sie haben versprochen den
internationalen terrorismus jetzt nicht
mehr zulassen die verbindung zwischen
den taliban und al qaida hat keine
einzige minute nachgelassenen letzten
wochen und monaten und das im übrigen
ist einer der zentralen gründe warum
afghanistans uns etwas angeht es am
anfang berechtigterweise 2001 es geht
darum dass von taliban kein
internationaler terrorismus mal ausgeben
und wir laufen gerade wieder in die
richtung und deshalb ist betrifft uns
alle
schlussendlich die frage an sie hat rom
an sie herr nouripour wie weiter herum
wir müssen die situation beobachten wie
sich die entwicklungen ergibt
insbesondere ob die taliban weiter land
gewinne machen können wie sich hier die
afghanische regierung dagegen wehren
kann müssen insbesondere um unsere
unsere ortskräfte uns bemühen das habe
ich gesagt und auch hier hilfeleistung
geben dass sie möglichst schnell dann
auch afghanistan verlassen können und
wir müssen uns auch da will ich darauf
hinweisen
auch wappnen wenn tatsächlich wieder die
taliban einen größeren einfluss in
afghanistan haben dass man dort kein
weiterer oder neuer terror in die welt
hinaus geht auch darauf müssen wir uns
sicherheitspolitisch einstellen wäre das
dann ein punkt tatsächlich vielleicht
wieder darüber nachzudenken dort kräfte
hin zu schicken
also wenn sie die frage an mich stellen
dann würde ich das jetzt zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt
ausschließen wollen wir haben jetzt
gerade entschieden dass wir unsere
kräfte abziehen so etwas ist auch
sicherlich nicht allein durch
deutschland möglich und ich kenne jetzt
auch keine politische forderung
jedenfalls von anderen fraktionen oder
parteien in deutschland die ein solches
anziehen haben das würde ich zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt sicherlich nicht
sehen januar wie weiter aus ihrer sicht
ich kenne die letzte forderung schon
nämlich von norbert röttgen von der cdu
csu fraktion ansonsten gebe ich aber im
kollegen recht dass unsere
öffentlichkeiten diesen abzug wollten
und das ist deshalb ist jetzt erfolgt
ich finde es extrem wichtig natürlich
die lokalen rauszuholen natürlich zu
beobachten wie es weitergeht es ist sehr
sehr wichtig jetzt nicht in eine panik
situation zu verfallen weder in
afghanistan noch bei uns um zu sagen ob
gott jetzt werden ganz viele leute
fliehen wir wissen es nicht es ist immer
noch möglich dass die taliban das land
nicht überrollen ich glaube genau
deswegen braucht das jetzt einfach ganz
viele hochrangige gespräche mit der
afghanischen regierung mit der
zivilgesellschaften vor allem mit den
frauen im land die haben allermeisten zu
verlieren haben taliban wieder kommen
ich habe hier gerade eine wortmeldung
von lisch es noch gelesen die würde ich
gern noch mitnehmen zum ende unseres
gesprächs alles was die taliban
bräuchten ist eine liebevolle umarmung
das könnte so einfach sein das ist ein
hehrer wunsch ein sehr idealistisches
ziel ob das was ich nicht funktionieren
würde ich habe meine zweifel aber ich
nehme das mal einfachsten mit lass das
hier stehen hat rom vielen dank für ihre
zeit herr nouripour auch schönen dank
dass sie zu uns gekommen sind und ich
sage euch vielen dank dass ihr mal
wieder dabei war im chat mitgemacht habt
und eure fragen gestellt hat immer hat
es viel spaß gemacht und ich sage bis
zum nächsten mal macht gut und tschüss